In this last section on language and thought, we're going to discuss judgement
and decision making. For example, when I was at home writing this lesson I kept
wonderign all day, should I eat that burrito that's in the refridgerator. Now
you may say, well that's a silly question. But not really if you think that the
way I answer it could have a profound effect on my health and weight. For
example, if I ate a burrito every day and didn't exercise, that could be
trouble for me. Every day we're faced with these types of situations and
questions. For example, are you going to go to that rock concert? What are you
going to wear today? Are you going to call that person back? So, in this
lesson, we'll learn about how we do make those judgments, and our decisions.